[Music]
i will say this dude
after after getting so many tests myself
recently
i started to think just weirdly about
germs which is you know
there are people who are conscious of
germs all the time but
i was thinking about specifically a
venue how
i think i feel like i've said this
before but the fact that venues just
have only like
four toilets and thousands of people
[ __ ] in that same toilet
it's a [ __ ] miracle that no one has
died from like a unique diarrhea or
something
dude the amount of public do you want to
[ __ ] bars i've taken a [ __ ] in
oh bro bro it's just like
imagine the amount of night clubs i've
taken a [ __ ] in which is a handful
probably like two or three but still the
fact that i didn't die of like
dysentery what whole chlamydia
you think your whole [ __ ] ins your
whole whole
your hole is exposed your whole hole is
exposed
the whole inside of your body is opened
up to this world
of germs that has been that has been
exposed to public [ __ ] for
years i mean we're talking maybe decades
you know bro
the fact that i mean if there was a
quick way to get a sickness it would be
to go into an environment like that and
just spread your cheeks
just like invite whatever is in the air
to just come on inside just pull up if
you could do one of those like
you know fart on command moves where you
inhale through your ass a little bit
you know some people can like breathe
through their ass i don't know anyone
that can breathe through their ass
you know some you've never seen someone
do it like like fart on purpose you have
to like in take air to
to do that dude people can know someone
who can do that they should be on only
fans because i've never
seen that in my life and that's one i
would pay for
how do you know all these unique ass
people cake sitters
command farters dude i like you know
i've heard of a command squirter you
know
squirting that's just peeing isn't it
no it's not p it's [ __ ]
isn't that just taking a pee no dude
it's unicorn
juice it's unicorn fluid man
it's not it's not pee fart
on command that's wild
yeah the only what if a dude's version
of of you know squirting after like a
prostate orgasm was
was just [ __ ] you know a prostate
orgasm
i'm so scared to give my prostate check
and that shit's gonna happen to me
oh can we talk about that actually that
dude who [ __ ] what did he do he shot
the doctor
he shot there was a guy in florida who
was getting a prosthetic exam
and he came and the guy was the guy
turned around and
shot the doctor he had a gun on him in
the doctor's office no way
i mean in florida no way do that can't
you
you can't just open carrie into a
[ __ ]
doctor's office well who's saying it was
open carry
i mean he didn't turn around in the
building and shoot him
did he maybe maybe he oh maybe it was
after the fact yeah he would have
bro that's pretty wild if a dude has a
[ __ ] sidearm on his hip
and you got to check his prostate i'd be
like give me that [ __ ]
i mean it's also [ __ ] wild to be so
mad about that
that that you drive to the dude's house
afterwards because i actually think
that's what happened now that you said
that
i remember that's reading that in the
article it is so dark
like that's you don't even get a little
like post nut clarity where you're like
really pissed off and then you're like
you know what actually
everything's cool i'm i'm gonna take a
nap instead he was upset because he made
him fall in love
yeah yeah exactly
i've never felt that way in my life
no one can know jesus no no one has ever
made me do that
dude i'm [ __ ] i know john mulaney has
done a whole bit about that but i'm
terrified of that bro getting a [ __ ]
hitting a prostate exam and your heart
is
i nails don't i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
dude you wouldn't care
imagine how much the doctor sees that
yeah it's probably
mad regular he's like all right it's
probably the most normal thing in the
world
doing a friend oh
i'm gonna have my intern here hold a
bucket underneath you're you're you're
like what
wait why why the bucket
you're just gonna get a little hard here
huh oh
and three two one and we're out it'll go
away in just a second oh
oh man man
splash zone you know
dude they turn you into a corner and
there's just
a crusty ass piece of carpet on the
ground you're like what's that for
yeah he's looking forward oh
why is there a target on the wall
just try to get the highest points just
fixate on it if you can
aim for the high score the highest
number of points
see if you can do better than the last
guy no
huh still dripping down the
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
jesus christ dude that's like that hole
you saw that um
uh that masturbation machine in china
that [ __ ] retweeted
oh bro well you're like huh
bro you thought of you thought a
fleshlight was dope hold on
hold on what about this [ __ ] you hear
about the vietnamese police
that seized over 300 000 used condoms
that were washed and packaged to be
resold
no yep no
washed how are they washing that [ __ ]
who's collecting them though where are
they getting them from
ooh they didn't think about that part i
want to know how they're washing them
i'm more curious about the process there
needs to be a
how it's made on that whole process it's
just
it's just kitchen sink dude oh
it's just one person with gloves on like
just standard cleaning gloves the yellow
ones
and then they hang dry them you just
just he's washing it like a [ __ ] like
a like a bar
pint glass he's just that's what it is
actually it's one of those
geysers that rockets up and they used to
clean glasses at a bar when they press
it and then it just rockets with water
they just no
it's got to be some like industrial
process where there's like a big bucket
of them
like in a in like sitting in a solution
and then there's just like
a minimum wage worker with [ __ ]
dishwasher gloves just like
putting them on like a like a series of
pegs it's like
they do it dumb fast
the condoms are placed in border for
washing 24 at a time
they are how it's made man yeah wow what
a show
call back dude that is a crazy i'm
feeling weirdly nostalgic right now
the condoms at the base and filled with
hydrogen peroxide
only to be re-lubricated later
[ __ ] there's like a testing period
where the condoms are on the pegs and
they just have like a [ __ ]
like a lego block of fleshlights and
they just go
oh my god it's a row of fleshlights that
are pointed down
yep and then the condoms are pointed up
and the belts are going the opposite
direction
real quick testing all of them like
multiple times it like it goes down it
turns then it comes back up
and then it moves to the next one goes
down turns comes back up
and then there's a [ __ ] way they're
shooting lube through the top of the
flashlight so that it
that's how it gets down and that's how
they get it all
looped up and then there's like there's
like a period where it has to be
artisanal
so they can legally legally market them
as handmade
it's just like an old lady with like
with like some weird like
you know like [ __ ] middle like
eastern europe clay looking [ __ ] and
she's like
this is something imported lube that is
manually and then she just manually
places it over the condoms and then it
goes into some kind of oven where it's
melted down and then they're
or it's difficult or it's the folding
technique oh yes
the one though maybe she just goes maybe
they have like a certain sort of
like two-handed technique where yeah and
it's
perfectly rolled and how do you do that
even
each condom is carefully packaged by one
individual
this ensures that the condom is not
tampered with by machinery
each condom goes through a stress test
and they're just filled up like water
balloons
good meticulously testing them all even
though they're all used
[Laughter]
refurbished condoms refurbished
you